bonjour François Bayrou
président du MoDem maire de Pau vous
êtes en direct de Pau dans les studios
de France Bleu merci à vous merci à eux
aussi ben on vient d'en parler à
l'instant commençons par là Monsieur
Bayrou c'est
l'UNESCO c'est me le monde entier c'est
me bien sûr des démons qu'il y a dans
cette guerre contre daesh depuis le
début mais de ce qui se passe en ce
moment des des trésors inestimables ce
qui est un peu le cœur j'allais presque
dire de notre civilisation dans ce musée
de mossure qui est en train de partir un
coup de massue
voyez ce n'est pas la première fois il y
a des comme vous en souvenez il y a des
événements plus anciens qui vont dans le
même sens les Bouddha de Damian et
d'autres des mausolées qui ont été
détruits et c'est un autre visage de la
barbarie n'est-ce pas la barbarie c'est
sa porte évidemment sur la vie des des
femmes et des hommes sur l'esclavage sur
la manière dont on écrase la liberté la
conscience et sa porte aussi sur des
biens inestimables qui appartiennent à
chacun d'entre nous et à chacun de ceux
qui les attaquaient détruisent et donc
cette barbarie là elle s'attaque aussi à
l'histoire même des peuples qui sont en
cause et je trouve que tout cela forme
l'ensemble qui justifie l'engagement la
volonté la mobilisation de tous ceux qui
veulent arrêter
mettre un terme si possible une dérive
qui blesse ce que nous avons de plus
profond alors justement Monsieur Bayrou
parce que c'est la polémique de ces 24
dernières heures qui n'est pas encore
éteinte qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
quatre parlementaires qui ont été voir
Bachar el-Assad
alors c'est pas la même chose vous voyez
on reste dans le même secteur il faut
t'éviter simplement que l'audit que nos
auditeurs imagine que c'est la que c'est
le même sujet non ce n'est pas le même
sujet mais le moins qu'on en puisse dire
c'est que c'est une démarche irréfléchie
irraisonné complètement
improvisée et qui porte atteinte
évidemment à toute la marge d'action
qu'une diplomatie solide peut avoir je
le dis d'autant plus que vous vous
souvenez sans doute que lorsqu'il a été
question de bombarder la Syrie et de
bombarder Bachar el-Assad pour pour le
chasser je me suis opposé à cette
démarche que je trouvais peu raisonnable
dans la mesure où chasser les uns
c'était mettre les autres à la place et
les autres c'est les djihadistes dont
nous parlions à l'instant
et donc j'ai appelé à la prudence mais
autant je pense que il faut une démarche
construite de la part de la communauté
internationale et notamment des Nations
Unies pour que le que les choses bougent
dans cette région du monde autant voir
des initiatives complètement
individuelles sans légitimité se
présentant comme officiel alors qu'elles
sont tous sauf officiels aussi par ceux
qui les reçoivent personnelles et sans
aucun doute des démarches manipulées
puisqu'elles vont jouer dans la main de
ce au contraire à qui il faut imposer
des changements profonds et faire
entendre raison et vous voyez que tout
cela c'est c'est comment dirais-je sans
plus aucun repère et que des hommes
politiques qui devraient avoir une
attitude de responsabilité ce livre à ce
genre de choses franchement c'est à
pleurer mais vous pensez que l'Élysée
peut ne pas être prévenu de ce genre
d'initiative c'est possible
oui je pense que tout est possible parce
que je pense que ce sont des démarches
individuelles protégées par les
autorités de Bachar el-Assad évidemment
puisqu'on va on va lui apporter des
cartes pour son propre jeu et donc ceci
c'est évidemment
ça manque absolument de sérieux et ça
manque aussi d'esprit de responsabilité
n'est-ce pas vous êtes un parlementaire
plus forte raison si vous avez des
responsabilités
au Parlement vous ne vous ne pouvez pas
vous
exonérer vous n'êtes pas une personne
individuelle vous allez à l'étranger
vous y allez en réalité vous êtes invité
parce que on veut que il apparaisse que
vous représentez quelque chose de très
important dans votre pays et vous allez
jouer ainsi contre
un certain nombre d'impératifs qui sont
ceux de la DIP assis de la France non je
trouve tout ça je trouve tout ça
déraisonnable et léger alors j'ai juste
une toute dernière chose sur le sujet
monsieur Bayo il y a quand même un
certain nombre de voix qui disent que on
a peut-être levé une forme de tabou en
tout cas qu'on ne peut pas ne pas poser
la question est-ce que oui ou non on
peut venir à bout daesh sans Bachar
el-Assad ah mais ceci est tout à fait
une autre chose j'ai dit à l'instant que
il fallait qu'une démarche construite
concerté avec des Nations Unies face
bouger les choses en Syrie parce que
c'est vrai que
on a en face de nous l'horreur de
l'horreur pour pour simplifier
c'est-à-dire une conduite des pratiques
une idéologie totalement barbare et
totalement destructrice de tout ce que
nous avons de précieux alors il faut
regarder les rapports de force il faut
faire en sorte que ces rapports de force
soient à l'avantage de ceux qui veulent
empêcher que ces gens
mais vous voyez bien que ceci ne se fait
pas en bricolant or c'est du bricolage
qu'on a en face de nous et du bricolage
irresponsable c'est des gens qui
réfléchissent pas ou c'est pas qui qui
ne voit pas les conséquences de leurs
actes et qui se prennent pour des
diplomates alors que d'une certaine
manière ils sont simplement dans dans
de puériles improvisations François
Bayrou tout autre chose vous étiez donc
héros au salon de l'agriculture vous y
étiez en même temps que Marine Le Pen
vous ne l'avez pas croisé elle a
sciemment battu un record de présence
elle est restée 9 heures elle a
évidemment fait exprès puisque François
Hollande était resté 8 heures c'est un
monde que vous connaissez bien
évidemment l'agriculture vous comprenez
cette attirance pour le Front national
est-ce que vous la croyez réel de la
part des agriculteurs
bon alors j'ai dit hier interrogé sur ce
point que pour ma part j'ai pas
l'intention de traiter cette question
sous l'angle des leçons de morale
ceux qui se drapent et qui disent mais
vous n'avez pas le droit de c'est pas du
tout la manière dont je pense les choses
je connais le bien de l'intérieur le
monde agricole je connais les angoisses
qui sont les siennes aujourd'hui des
difficultés très grandes et l'inquiétude
profonde c'est un monde qui pour de
large partie de cet ensemble ne se voit
pas un avenir et ne se représente pas
comme ce qu'ils ont été pendant des
siècles c'est-à-dire des gens qui sont
reconnus pour être les amis de la nature
et pour nourrir les autres et c'était
très valorisant naturellement donc
aujourd'hui ils ont cette inquiétude là
mais c'est un monde intelligent le monde
de l'agriculture c'est un monde
pour une raison très simple c'est que le
B le pays a besoin d'une politique
différente d'une alternative d'un
changement profond parce que les cadres
de notre de nos institutions et de nos
partis politiques sont usés et que vous
n'avez pour bâtir cette alternative le
choix entre l'extrémisme et ceux qui au
contraire avec un avec un sentiment
profond et qui dure depuis longtemps une
thèse défendue depuis longtemps ont
envie de changer les choses en étant en
même temps
reconstructeur et modéré c'est-à-dire
pas du tout jeter le pays dans des
aventures des sociétés dans lesquelles
on se laisse aller à n'importe quel
risque n'importe quel affirmation et
est-ce qu'on y va est-ce que au regard
de ce qui s'est passé notamment ces
dernières semaines particulièrement dans
le dos est-ce qu'on y va vers ce grand
courant du centre est-ce qu'on s'en
éloigne pour l'instant on ne ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas évident parce que c'est
un combat
c'est une chose que nous avons à bâtir
c'est quelque chose qui est
devant nous comme un but à atteindre et
c'est tout sauf évident puisque nous
vivons nous sommes le seul pays d'Europe
continentale en tout cas le seul pays à
vivre avec des règles qui sont faites
pour empêcher que cette alternative
entre autres la règle électorale est
absurde de regarder combien de français
sont exclus de la représentation et de
quel droit qu'est-ce qui fait que le
Parti socialiste ou l'UMP doivent avoir
la totalité de la représentation alors
que l'extrême droite et le centre et
l'extrême gauche en sont pour ainsi dire
exclu qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
justifie ça qui sont quelle est la
légitimité de ceux qui ont décidé cela
donc
la Bâtie pour éviter les travers de la
quatrième alors peut-être des choses ont
changé depuis Fabienne synthèse ça n'a
rien à voir la Cinquième République
c'est tout à fait autre chose c'est la
solidité de l'exécutif mais personne n'a
jamais écrit à l'origine de la Cinquième
République que il fallait que la moitié
des Français soit exclu de la
représentation ça ça c'est fait plus
tard un peu par accident et pour ma part
en tout cas je crois pas que ça soit du
tout constitutif de la Cinquième
République c'est un proportionnelle en
tout cas on a compris ce que vous nous
disiez François Bayrou pardon ne vous
interrompre voici gibbiran baume
et l'autre info part de Bourges ouais le
Berry.fr se préoccupe d'un débat de fond
qui va intéresser Monsieur Bayrou et qui
dépasse le cas du Berry on sait à quel
point le débat sur l'ouverture des
magasins le dimanche à agiter les
esprits politiques et notamment avec le
vote de la loi Macron mais il y a aussi
des citoyens qui ont d'autres projets
que de ce planter des clous dans les
doigts 12 dimanche par an je parle pour
moi et elle elle dit donc de quoi
s'agit-il et bien d'une mobilisation de
ceux qui veulent comme le propose
d'ailleurs un amendement d'Aurélie
Philippe Petty à la loi Macron que les
villes qui discutent de l'ouverture
dominicale des magasins des battent
aussi de la question de l'ouverture des
bibliothèques et pas que le dimanche
d'ailleurs certains soirs de semaine
aussi parce que les horaires de nos
bibliothèques ne sont pas raccords avec
l'emploi du temps de ceux qui ont la
chance d'avoir un boulot alors les
exemples cités à Bourges montrent bien
que des utilisateurs de bibliothèques
voudraient bien qu'elle ferme plus tard
on en entend même certains évoqué la
bibliothèque comme lieu de vie de
partage familial forte de ces demandes
la directrice des bibliothèques de
Bourges sont déjà élargir les heures
d'ouverture le lundi jour de fermeture
de la médiathèque mais comme d'habitude
et Monsieur Bayrou le sait en France la
décision reviendra aux politiques pour
le meilleur et pour le pire même si
l'hypothèse de l'ouverture dimanche
séduit pas mal d'usagers alors il y a
une pétition justement oui qui défend
l'élargissement de l'ouverture des
bibliothèques ces bibliothèques sans
frontières qui depuis quelques temps a
lancé un appel ouvrant plus les
bibliothèques pour qu'elles soient
accessible le soir le weekend dépendant
les vacances de façon à ne plus
pénaliser que ceux qui devraient en être
les bénéficiaires alors on n'arrête pas
de nous casser les oreilles avec le
fameux esprit du 11 janvier voilà enfin
du concret plutôt que des grands messes
un peu ostentatoires qui tiennent plus
de l'émotion spontanée peut-être et du
réflexe que de la réflexion et ben
ouvrons à tous et d'urgence de vrais
lieux de connaissances de culture de
savoir einstein disait la seule chose
que vous ayez absolument besoin de
savoir c'est l'emplacement d'une
bibliothèque je crois qu'il savait de
quoi il parlait en ces temps de
confusion de négation de complotisme
d'intolérance de violence de folie de
barbarie vous le disiez monsieur Barroux
quel meilleur espace que nos
bibliothèques pour éclairer encadrer
conseiller rattraper tous ceux qui sont
paumés on en viendrait presque à se
demander Monsieur Bayrou pourquoi vous
qui fut ministre de l'Éducation pendant
4 ans ou de présidents vous n'avez pas
agi en ce sens alors c'était d'ailleurs
dans vos propositions en 2012
et c'était dans mes propositions 2012 et
dans mes réalisations à Pau depuis la
dernière élection en effet une des
premières décisions que nous avons
prises c'est d'augmenter de 30%
d'élargir de 30% les horaires
d'ouverture de la médiathèque des
bibliothèques à Pau et non seulement
nous l'avons fait mais nous l'avons fait
sans dépenser un euro de plus uniquement
par la réorganisation des équipes et
donc en effet moi je trouve que c'est ça
c'est de la civilisation voilà de la
vraie ça c'est de la civilisation de la
vraie que les bibliothèques soient
ouvertes et qu'on puisse y accéder à